[Musik]
und damit letzten zur leute ich habe
heute jemand ganz besonders an meiner
seite und das hier ist ein ganz
besonderes wieder hier sieht neben ihr
lager lara ist die freunde von max von
meinem kleinen bruder und lara ist
expertin für eine gewisse sendung welche
sendung ist aus plastik leute ich habe
schon länger mal drüber nach hat mein
video promis unter palmen zu machen
jetzt ist die serie vor zwei wochen
geändert und ich dachte mir da jetzt
wird's zeit wenn nicht heute dann und
dann hab ich's lage fragt bereit erklärt
und ja ich habe noch keine ahnung von
promise unter palmen du hast alles
gesehen bis auf das finale das heißt wir
machen das ganze so damit ich mir keine
relevanten szene rein ziehe lara bild
märz die szenen zeigen die am
wichtigsten sind um sich eine andere von
promis oder feiern zu verschaffen und
dann wenn wir das ganz kommentieren weil
wir die leute fangen damit der kleinen
vorstellungsrede das erste video lautet
die schönheits-op des stars bestätigt so
weiter wie vor von brust op bis pns
vergrößerung schau mal rein
also ich muss sagen da habe ich habe
schon so viel gesehen aber dies also mit
die berühmte also okay ganz kurz mal
leute als kontext also dieser clip
findet relativ am anfang von den ganzen
clips und eine sendung statt das ist es
die vorstellungsrunden das nicht ganz
relativ weit am anfang und das ist
einfach mal so ein bisschen aufpassen
und sich dort kennen zu lernen
die vorstellung und dann sagt man dass
man als alte frau keine balance hat ja
alles klar der wirklich einen wilden
stil das ist dass das ist eine gras
frisur
das ist nicht ideal das ist klar das ist
ja ne yo vertrocknen brüder wende zum
friseur ist aber sagt bruder machen wir
einfach wie sie machen
ok ok relativ spezielle gesprächs dem
würde ich schon mal sagen sondern sollte
wie gesagt ich sie zum ersten mal jetzt
irgendwie wissen die videomaterial von
dieser sendung
das war direkt ihr mann ja wieso wieso
haben die sich nicht über kernphysik
unterhalten oder über über die
politische lage im 16 jahrhundert in
deutschland war das wurde dann auch
sondern haben da haben die oktober
gesprochen aber es wurde durchgeführt
okay leute es war vor dem kontext und
das vor 14 tagen gestern war das glaube
ich diesen beitrag bestimmt gesehen auf
instagram von joko und klaas so thema
sexuelle übergriffe gegen frauen er
macht einfach im fernsehen soll übrigens
sat 1 prosieben ist dieselbe
sendergruppe pro sieben schreit so dass
aus sat 1 ist ja ok
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ronald zieht blank die ent die bewohner
sind entsetzt vom anblick leute das ist
das deutsche bildungsfernsehen dafür
sind diverse menschen gestorben
hinkriegen damit deutschland heutzutage
sind die live erleben keine
schlafenszeit für die promis unter
palmen während sich désirée pomper
center palm aus plastik bitte ist ja
keine richtigen dafür vollständig
bedeckt enthüllt sich ronald fast
komplett also svs das geht überhaupt
nicht vor ein ich glaube dieser
vatterodt dieser ich habe den typen mit
google ich da war früher doch mal der
war vize bürgermeister von hamburg
wollen ist dann irgendwie doch irgend so
ein drogen skandal ist irgendwie
geflüchtet nach südamerika oder so und
jetzt egal wie kriegen sie ihre leute
zusammen new york wo kein kläger da auch
dass man sich wirklich einmal getroffen
hatte
das war das war wirklich einfach dass
man also leute ich weiß ist das ist auch
so sexy frauen soll es auch darum geht
irgendwas schockieren das zu zeigen
aber sowas gibt doch keiner denkt danach
denke mein tag ist besser geworden davon
man schaut sich das daran denkt sich so
was das niveau dabei ja das ist so dass
diese nicht nur den titel vor allem die
profis unter palmen gesehen haben wissen
es diese eine extreme szene mit diesem
ronald und claudia fda habe ich da haben
sogar schon von gehört so das werde ich
in meinem video nicht zeigen es
beinhaltet als nächstes hat lange auf
uns vorbereitet heute das video desiree
wird handgreiflich gegenüber claudia
streit eskaliert völlig diese tücher
habe ich mit absicht dort hingelegt und
verband hat sie jedes mal in die ecke
geschmissen hat ihren giften sich auch
den ganztag so an oder weniger also es
geht nur um vergrößerungen
verkleinerungen wäre gerade nachts nackt
rum liegt und streit ja eigentlich geht
es meistens wie sie was war das macht
die klar dass diese braun
also ich weiß alles nämlich getriggert
von der bühne eigentlich ja also ich
weiß nicht mal kann ich sagen
aber du musst dir selbst ein bild davon
machen die sind dreckig also so schön
wenn sie dreckig sein wenn man sie
direkt sind sie dreckig ich habe dir da
hingelegt es gibt noch mehr aber ich
finds auch fest dass du wirklich so viel
stress haben und sich über so belanglose
sachen streiten obwohl die einfach nur
den ganzen tag ja nichts zu tun haben
chillen einfach nur da an dieser bude
weißt doch dann ist sowas doch voll
schließlich motto also jetzt wohne weise
wie irrelevant ist bittet wo handtücher
liegen und wo nicht was man was macht er
für ein dreimaliger also das ist auf
anhieb erstmal richtig krass unseren
partnern wieder der gift der spuckt ja
wirklich gift warum weil die hand sich
ja nicht darlegen wo er will
okay es ist sein haushalt bleibt alles
so wie sie ist es gibt noch mehr hier
drinnen kameras herum
[Gelächter]
guck mich nicht so an dass das thema ist
jetzt um seine sprüche kotzen mich
wirklich mittlerweile an das ist mein
voller ernst es ist auch kein spaß
mächten ist unter aller sau
hier bricht er sonst nicht so nur ist
der sagt der andere typ kriegs von
seinem manager gesagt okay also nur bei
promis dabei ist da musste richtig drama
machen das ist perfekt dann geht die
ganze aufmerksamkeit auf sich und seine
karriere auf und siehst du von den blick
ansieht es wirklich so das juckt mich
nicht so nicht überreden
und die positive live herrscht positive
die hashtags papers läuft es geht zum
bild war lara das ist so hat sie mit 13
gemacht hat das irgendwie sie mit zwar
mit so einer koppel somit 13 jahren so
kann man's mit 30
[Musik]
sie sind wie sie einfach auf den vogel
schießt ein tor das dann dass der
schnabel und jetzt fehlt nur noch die
mama vogel ist es den wurm
[Musik]
was ist also eine sendung alter ja das
war auch so ein moment wo ich gesagt
alter das ist echt krankhaft also so
viel trash habe ich noch nie sich das
wird vorher gar nicht so recht
authentisch so sie rennt so zu ihr hin
stellt sich so perfekt vor ihr hin und
stimmt sie einmal so laut als hätte
jemand gesagt jetzt geht mal hin und
schob sie mal leicht damit der
körperkontakt haben die er aber die
diesmal ist sympathisch das war mein
erster einblick in die sendung promis
unter palmen aus plastik leute lager von
ex dabei seien heute wenn ihr noch bock
habt dass wir uns noch mehr reinziehen
davon es gibt sicher noch einige
kritiker stellen dann schaut man das
gerne die kommentare und lassen auf dem
detailliert vorgestellt das video oben
könnt ihr mann abonnieren
sein letzter raus